بصوره صادمه لا بالارقام نشرت اللجنه
الدوليه للصليب الاحمر ماذا فعل التغير
المناخي وين في العراق الصور هي نتائج
مسابقه للتصوير الفوتوغرافي عن اثار
التغير المناخي والثقت فداحه التدهور
البيئي الذي تعيشه بلاد الرافدين تعاني
الاراضي العراقيه في السنوات الاخيره من
تفاقم خطر التغير المناخي مع تسارع وتيره
الجفاف وشح المياه والتصحر وتقلص المساحات
الخضراء يذكر طبعا ان العراق خامس البلدان
الاكثر تعرضا للتدهور المناخي عالميا اذ
شهد عام 2013 اكثر من 300 عاصفه رمليه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات